hi everyone thank you for coming to my
talk in this talk I'm going to talk
about a generalized multi-calibration
method happy map
this is a joint work with my wonderful
collaborators sincere to work at the
trending
so machine learning has been widely used
in all daily lives especially in many
consequential domains nowadays including
College Automation and that disease
diagnosis
typically a machine learning algorithm
only give us a prediction value for
example in disease diagnosis the machine
learning algorithm typically give us a
probability of say a patient getting
certain disease given some
characteristics of this patient
recently
people are not only interested in those
prediction values but they are also
interested in the assertive
quantification
so in stock we are going to
introduce a general framework that can
give us a fair and reliable uncertainty
quantification in machine learning
predictions
foreign
quantification a state of art method is
called conformal prediction which I'm
going to introduce below
answer conformal prediction is a
post-processing algorithm
so suppose we have an input X which is a
covariate vector
typically a machine learning algorithm
will only give us a values denoted by F
hat
the conformal prediction one two wants
to one step further to construct an
interval called C hat
okay this is a post-processing step
a c hat is constructed based on the IID
training samples x i y i and the C hat
is to satisfy the following inequality
basically it's saying that given a new
data point x New Y new drawn from the
same training distribution
then the coverage probability of theta y
Nu is included in hat C of X Nu should
be quite close to a minus Delta
here this Alpha is quite a small and
typically is called the tolerance level
okay this is a traditional conformal
prediction framework
however this framework have two
potential issues
one is distribution shift and another is
algorithmic fairness we are going to
introduce below
so first of all
the traditional conformal prediction
takes the probability over the
distribution that is the same as the
training distribution
okay in many applications the test
distribution d-test might be quite
different from the training distribution
teaching
so in this talk we'll consider the
following
assumption called correct shift
assumption which is commonly used in a
transfer learning literature
basically this assumption assumes that
the marginal distribution of X are
different on the training and test
domains on the other hand a conditional
distribution of a y given X are the same
okay
so we want to guarantee the coverage
validity under this distribution shift
if now the X New Y Nu is taken from the
new test distribution how can we
guarantee that the current probability
is still quite close to one Mass Delta
so this is our first problem
there are some prior Works considered
this
scenario however
they require the knowledge of the
following density ratio of the marginal
distribution of x
typically this is distance ratio is
unknock
and in some extreme case say we don't
have any data from the test distribution
then there's no way to even estimate
this density ratio
so the question Still Remains
how can we
to guarantee this coverage in a setting
that
the test distribution might be unknown
but it's different I know okay
as we mentioned the second issue of the
conformal prediction is algorithm
algorithmic fairness so the original
conformal prediction only guarantees the
overall
coverage right so now suppose we are
given a collection of protected
demographic groups
script A
there's a notion called equalized
coverage that asks
therefore all group
a in the script A the conditional
coverage
is the conditional coverage probability
needs to be quite still be quite close
to one minus Delta
okay so this notion is called equalized
coverage and this is characterized the
fairness for the uncertainty
quantification problem
in the same paper who proposed the
equalized coverage notion they proposed
a method to construct an interval C hat
that satisfied this notion
however
there are methods require the knowledge
of locality assumption that the script A
are destroyed so basically saying that
all the groups in this script A need to
be destroyed
this assumption might be too strong in
some cases so for example if we consider
a racial group and gender groups those
two groups are foreign
[Music]
overlapping
right so what if we want the equalized
coverage notion hold for those
overlapping groups and moreover say what
if we have infinitely many groups that
we want to protect
can we do in that case
and still there's no method in the
literature testifying those motions
so in order to address both problems
let's first rewrite the tool coverage
probabilities
so for the under the correct shift
setting the coverage probability can be
rewrite and Rewritten as the following
expectation form
okay similarly for The Equalizer
coverage probability uh we can also
rewrite this
um
formula
as in this expectation form
if we compare those two formulas
with the observe thumb similarity as we
show here
so first of all those formulas include
this indicator function
Ally both formulas
as a form say
this indicator function multiplied from
other functions
okay
given this similarity
we can then do one step further
we can rewrite the coverage validity
under the correlation setting in this
formula using this Superior notion where
we take Superior over this density ratio
basically is saying that if the test
distribution
has this density ratio in the script
acid
then we can guarantee
that the coverage probability
under this new test distribution is
quite close to Walmart's data
okay similarly we have the the similar
interpretation for the equalized
coverage notion
okay
then given this similarity
okay
we introduce a notion called as happy
multi-calibration
which has the following expression
if we take say this
rad function C to be the density ratio
and we take the blue function as equal
to say 1 minus Delta one one minus this
indicator function then we can recover
the one-sided version of the uncertainty
quantification problem under the
coverage shift set
in our paper we discussed how to
transfer transform this one-sided
version to an interval
but in this talk for the Simplicity of
presentation we will skip this you can
check our paper for more details of this
transforming
moreover if we take status C to be this
indicator function as to be the same
form then we recover the equalized
coverage notion
okay
so this has happened multi-calibration
can be applied to this special settings
in fact this s-hap multi-calibur
calibration calibration notion is very
general and it can be used to unify many
Notions considered in the
multi-calibration literature
for example if we take this C to have
this indicator function form where this
i-being is some place to specify that
being the intervals
okay and if we take this S2 to be F
minus y
then we recover the multi-calibration
notion
moreover if we take this C to have this
indicator function form then we recover
the multi accuracy notion
okay
furthermore if we take say this C to be
the indicate the density ratio as again
to be the F minus y then we recover the
universal adaptivity
method uh recently proposed in a pnas
paper
um last but not least our notion can
also be used to recover a lot of other
Notions in the literature including the
low degree multi-calibration Omni
predictors multi-valued architecture
okay
um so first of all we want to
remark that our notion is quite a
general
secondly we also want to note that
our notion and also our result and
algorithms are inspired by all those
amazing Works seminal and prior works
okay there are many connections between
our notion and those works please refer
to our paper for a more detailed
discussion
then given that as happy multi
calibration notion will propose the
following algorithm to achieve that
notion
okay because this is a post-processing
algorithm that map any input function F0
to a final input ft that satisfies a
happy multi-calibration notion recorded
algorithm happy map it maps and
algorithms to satisfy the happy notion
so this algorithm is actually quite
simple it's simply a variant of the
gradient boosting algorithm
in the central part of this algorithm we
first so we found use the weak learning
to fund a function CT in the script C
that violates the happy
multi-calibration notion and then based
on the CT we Implement one step of grid
descent
okay so this is a happy map algorithm
during this happy map algorithm we have
the following result
given certain iterations
okay the resulting output F will satisfy
the S happy body calibration
okay
given this result we now apply this
result to the two problems we described
about
so the first application is the coverage
under the correlative shift set
suppose now we have a test distribution
okay it can be unknown
and that has this distribution as the
density has the marginal distribution P
test
that where the density ratio is quite
close
to the script C the distance between the
script C and the density ratio is quite
small and upbounded by Beta if this
condition is satisfied
then we can guarantee that the coverage
probability under this new test
distribution is quite close to one minus
Delta with tolerance level of plus beta
okay
so our algorithm can guarantee value the
coverage even if we don't know the test
distribution
okay
secondly if we apply the happy map
algorithm to the equalized coverage
setting we can get the following
result
okay so even if we consider the
overlapping cases okay and moreover even
if say the script they have infinitely
many groups
I'll have your map algorithm can give us
a hat C of X that satisfy this equalized
coverage notion
okay so this is our second application
moreover in our paper we also give
say the following no harm theorem
before we introduce the result let me
introduce a few Notions basically this
theorem described that
given the coverage guarantee the happier
math algorithm also give us a quiet good
interval in terms of the interval length
okay
so let me introduce a few notations
first so suppose we use f star Delta to
denote the Delta quantile function of
the conditional distribution of Y given
X
okay one can prove that when y given X
is symmetric
and the shortest one minus Delta
prediction interval Justified equals the
coverage will take the form of this
system of x
okay
then our no hand theorem says that if
the c0 the input
okay if the initialization c0 is quite
close to this C star
then the output
C hat
will have a similar length
okay so so if this C star is quite close
to the optimal interval system
which in this case the right hand side
will be quite small
and then the result tells us that
this the left hand side will also be
very small implying that C hat will also
be quite close to system
so this theorem tells us that even if c0
doesn't satisfy the equalized coverage
but after the happy map outward
we can always guarantee the C hat to
satisfy the equalized coverage meanwhile
if C hat is close to system
then the C hat will also be quite close
to sister
it will not destroy the interval length
it doesn't sacrifice the intervalence of
guarantee equalize coverage
and so this is what the no hand theorem
tells us
because I'll help you map algorithm is
is a quite a general framework
so in our paper in addition to the
conformal prediction under the
distribution shift and the equalized
coverage setting we also apply this
framework to more problems including
accuracy transfer and also missing data
analysis so if you are interested please
refer to our paper
now let me conclude this talk with some
discussions
uh so first of all I'll help you map
framework is used for prediction
functions it's used to post process set
prediction functions
nowadays in transfer learning literature
the Deep Learning Community realized
that the representation functions the
multivariates representation functions
sometimes is more useful than the
prediction functions
and this idea has been used say in the
pre-training and the fixed feature
transfer learning literature
so can is it possible to combine this
map framework to this pre to this
representation function then
this might be an interesting Direction
another problem we want to discuss is
the complexity of the script C as we
have seen in the athletic quantification
under the distribution shift set
The Wider or the bigger the script C is
the more test distributions we can
include to guarantee the valid coverage
right so
the power of C the larger the C is the
better the coverage probability is
on the other hand
our algorithm
running time will depend on the
complexity of the AC so the larger City
will take a longer time to run the
algorithm
can we have a trade-off between this
so this is another interesting question
okay so I will stop here and thank you
very much for your listening